special night for the Vegas gold Knights
raising their Banner their first ever
Stanley Cup Banner so certainly something I was
always hoping for it'll be quite a moment it'll
be that it'll cap it all off I think we're
all looking forward to taking a couple of
minutes to look back and then put it behind us
when the puck drops and get going try to do it
again the banner gives us some incredible closure
I think everybody's going to be pretty emotional
seeing it go up it's going to be there forever
something that we're very proud of it's been a
lot of great memories made this year that was the
most fun I've ever had playing hockey so you want
to give yourself an opportunity to be there
[Applause] again if you win one can you win
another and see if you can do something incredibly
special and win a few in terms of Vegas to deliver
a Stanley Cup like we did our jobs and and we
want to stay in Lake C and now it's time to get
back to work and everybody's going to be ready
to play us we saw that in the preseason they're
going to play us hard and the challenge is to
meet those challenges and see if we can win
[Music] again
[Music]